unity a cross-platform game engine for
building 2d and 3d experiences made
famous for democratizing the immense
challenge of game development it was
created in copenhagen denmark and first
released in 2005. today it's the magic
behind many popular games like the 2d
among us
the 3d monument valley augmented reality
apps like pokemon go first-person
shooters like escape from tarkov as well
as interactive simulations and
animations beyond the gaming industry
the engine itself is written in c plus
plus but allows developers to write
their code in the more approachable c
sharp in addition it provides a powerful
graphical editor allowing you to draw
shapes work with cameras and apply
materials without having to write a
single line of code every game object
can have a variety of components like a
mesh to define its actual physical shape
a mesh renderer to apply materials and
lighting to an object and physics
components like rigidbody and colliders
that simulate things like gravity and
collisions in the real world and finally
you can extend an object with your own c
sharp code to make it do something
interesting like take hit points when it
runs into a bad guy to build your first
video game right now install unity hub
create a new project then open up the
editor you'll be greeted with a 3d scene
that contains a light source and a
camera a scene is like a game level that
you're developing while the camera is
the point of view of the player to
create a game of dodgeball let's add a
plane to be the ground a cylinder for
the player and a sphere for the ball
select an object then hit y on your
keyboard to move rotate and scale it to
your liking hit the play button and
notice how these shapes don't do
anything but if we add a rigid body to
the objects all of a sudden they're now
impacted by the laws of gravity
currently they look pretty boring but we
can make them look cool by creating a
material and then drag it onto the
shapes and now to make this game
playable let's add a script component to
it and then open it in vs code it
contains a class with two methods to
implement your code start is called once
at the very beginning of the game while
update is called on every frame while
the game is being played and there's
also fixed update that runs at the same
frame rate as the physics engine now to
move our player around we can define a
public property for the rigid body which
contains a bunch of different properties
and methods to move the object around
now assign an actual value from the game
to that property by dragging the rigid
body component to it in the editor in
the fixed update method we can first use
input to detect when a user presses the
arrow keys and then call the move
position method on the rigid body to
move it hit the play button and you
should now be able to move your player
around from there we can add a script to
the ball that will add force to it when
the game starts to roll it across the
screen and we can also run code when the
two objects collide by defining the on
collision enter method congratulations
you just built a video game this has
been unity in 100 seconds if you want to
see more short videos like this hit the
like button and subscribe and let me
know if you want to see a full unity
tutorial in the comments thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one